An Iranian scientist says that he has created a time machine
Woah, woah, woops. The tiny invisible
bullshit detector I invented is going crazy!
I don't know why.
I'm Anthony. And yes, Ali Rezaei,
a scientist at the Iranian Center
for Strategic Innovations, has created
a device he calls The Aryayek
Time Machine. You touch it,
and it predicts the next 5 to 8 years
of your life with 98%
accuracy. Prints your future out, right
on paper. He just can't
show it to anyone or explain
how it works, right now. I told my totally
real girlfriend, who lives in Niagara falls and
is a supermodel about this, and she was like
so, he's lying...
and he named it wrong? Because that's not
actually a time machine. Then she tried to make out
with me, again. But this brings
up some really great questions.
Is there any way for us to actually
see the future and will we
ever be able to travel through time.
So, as of right now, we've got
no clue how we'd see into the future.
Bright side, we already have the ability
to see into the past. We actually do it all
the time. See light travels at a
186,000 miles per second,
right? And the farther something is from us
the longer it takes the light from it
to get here, and that's where the term light years
comes from. It takes light from the north
star 430 years to
get to us. So, when you look up at the north star
you're seeing it as it was
430 years ago. If you could create
an insanely huge telescope and
take a look at the Curiosity Rover on the surface
of mars, you'd see everything it was
doing 3 minutes ago. Even looking at
this screen right in front of you ,
taking into account the speed of light
and your brain's processing time, you're seeing
something 3 hundredths of a second
old. You are always looking into the past,
you can't help it. Travelling through time
as opposed to seeing through time,
that's a different story. We're all
actually travelling through time right now
at the speed of 1 hour per
hour. Not super exciting,
I know. But, there is a way to slow that down.
The closer an object
moves to the speed of light, the slower
time moves for that object. This happens on a
really small case for astronauts. So,
the space shuttle takes of at
17,500 miles an hour, and
when the astronaut comes back
they're a millisecond younger
than they would've been if they had stayed home. If
you could travel 500 light years away from earth
and then back at 99.95%
of the speed of light, you would land a
thousand years into the future and
it would've been only 10 years for you.
Great, let's do it! Hook it up! Well...
here's the issue. Einstein's
theory of special relativity. See, the faster an
object moves, the more mass it has.
The more mass it has, the more energy it takes
to move. So, travelling at the
speed of light, would take infinite
energy. And as impossible as that sounds
getting back from the future
or travelling into the past, that's even more
insane. We are talking about Sci-fi stuff,
like worm holes and cosmic
strings and space time curvature
and all sorts of things that may not exist
and if they do exist they would either
destroy you or a galaxy
when you try to poke at them. Stephen Hawking
had this theory called Chronology Projection
Conjecture. It basically means that the
laws of physics will not allow anyone
to go back in time. He thinks that no matter
how close we come, some new obstacle
is always gonna pop up to keep us from
doing it. Anyone else have a headache? Short
version: We can see the past,
we can travel to the future, and we
cannot switch that up. At least not
yet. And probably not with a box
some guy refuses to demonstrate
for anyone. But let's say we made it happen. Where
would you go? The future or the past?
I would go future, because, number 1,
there are too many diseases in the past
and not enough hover boards. Let me know down below
and subscribe for more DNews.